so let's see
if you were to invest
100 a month
from age 25 to age 65 or age 30 to age
70.
40 years
100 a month
let's put it in a roth ira so that it
grows tax-free
and i'm going to recommend a good growth
stock mutual fund
that has an average annual return
of 12
i own one that's done that for over 75
years
average
now some years it makes 18 and some
years it makes four
but the average annual return
is about 20 is about 12
for 75 years so let's just say you did
that
now i know some people think that can't
happen but this is an example to help
you understand how numbers work
and i've done it
my 401k has been funded and
my roth iras have been funded and
anything else i could fund has been
funded because i even though i'm a
natural spender i figured out that i
would have more to give and more to live
if i saved
and invested
and i've done a lot of that in good
growth stock type mutual funds now were
you doing that in a growth stock mutual
fund were it to average 12 percent were
you to
put a hundred dollars a month in
now what do you spend a hundred dollars
on
i'll guarantee you this 95 of you
listening to me right now do not do a
unique written budget every month unique
to that month
almost no one does
those that do however find all kinds of
money that's being lost
because your checking account is a
freaking sieve
money leaks out of it like you're
sending it to congress or something
you have no idea where your money goes
and you make more than your parents made
you make more than a lot of your friends
make and you make more than any other
country in the world virtually
personal income
and you're freaking broke
and so let's just let's just establish
here
that you can find a hundred dollars
latte breath
let's establish that you could find a
hundred dollars
mr and mrs cable
you spend a hundred dollars
on things you don't even realize you did
it you impulse more than a hundred
dollars at target every month
the reason they check your receipts at
costco and sams on the way out the door
is not to make sure you didn't shoplift
it's because it's federal law you spend
200 or you're not allowed out
i think it's easy if we sit here and
discuss it a minute to think about 100
100 is a lot of money
but a hundred dollars invested every
month
every
month
from age 25 to age 65 averaging 12
percent and a good growth stock mutual
fund roth ira is 1 million
176 000
so if you're listening to this show
and you are
under 40 years old
and you don't retire with a million
dollars
that's no one's fault but yours
it's your
fault
in this country
if you retire broke
it's your fault
because you made a freaking fortune
in your working lifetime
you work your butt off your whole life
and you have nothing to show for it
nothing
it's ridiculous
it's absolutely ridiculous
america it is
way past time
for a renaissance in the art
of personal finance
it is way past time for you to get your
freaking act together
for every one of you listening to not
retire a millionaire is absurd
it's absurd
average household income in america
today is 50 000
if you say fifteen percent of that
that's seventy five hundred dollars
a year
if you do
that in the decent in your 401k with no
match
into roth iras into good growth stock
mutual funds
you would retire
with around seven and a half million
dollars
if you say 15 of your income
i don't know if i agree with your set of
assumptions well shut up
unless you do something about it
because my set of assumptions have made
me rich
so why don't you use my set of
assumptions instead of your set of
assumptions because you're sitting on
your assumption
doing nothing
it's time for you to get up off your
assumption and go save some money
way past time
don't you think
so maybe i'm wrong
seven and a half million
let's say i'm half wrong so you end up
with 3 million bucks shut up
shut up
maybe you can't save 15 percent of your
income
because you're so deeply in debt and
you've not followed these steps to get
out of debt well then follow the steps
and get out of debt so that you can
well maybe you save half that amount
and so you only end up with
oh let's say okay let's just do this
instead of seven and a half million
let's say that i'm 90
wrong because you're a loser
let's just call it that you're a loser
and i'm 90
wrong
that's 750 000
you would have
which is a whole heck of a lot more than
social insecurity
some of you are walking around right now
and your best shot at retirement is
you're thinking
i sure hope the government which is well
known for its ability to handle money
will take care of me well what a stupid
butt plan is that
that's ridiculous
a hundred dollars a month
saved
from age 25 to age 65 is 1 million 176
000
there is no excuse for you to retire
broke
15 of the average household income in
america saved from age 30 to age 70 age
25 to age 65 average household income
being
fifty thousand fifteen percent of that
being seventy five hundred
is seven and a half million dollars if
i'm half wrong it's three million
dollars
and let's just let's just go with the
assumptions here for a second okay since
we're talking about assumptions
i set you up in an average
household income and for 40 years you
never got a raise
using those numbers
now let me help you with this if you
started average and you don't get a
raise for 40 years you are a loser
starting at average is one thing but if
you start at average and you don't get a
dime raise for 40 years you're a loser
losers in our country can retire
millionaires
isn't that
bizarre that's how dynamic this economy
is
but you're too freaking worried about
the bachelor or who got thrown off the
island to get control of your own life
and your own expenses and sit down and
do a budget and look in the mirror at
your immature self and say no so you can
put a couple of hundred bucks away a
month
so you can retire with dignity instead
of being a burden on society and on your
children
you can't give to anybody because you're
too freaking broke to help anybody else
and you've got all these great ideas
about how other people need help you
want to find out who needs help get you
a mirror you need help
it's time to save money people
it's time
to save
money
this is the dave ramsey show
so